my name is Stefan case I'm the wine
director at Eleven Madison Park and we
are here today to talk about wine labels
why they're important what's written on
them and how it relates to what's in the
bottle moving something a little bit
more difficult
this is burgundy again the information
that puts you in Burgundy is written on
the label but once you're at this point
it's important to know sort of where in
Burgundy and how what's what else is
written on the label is gonna be late as
you can see clearly much more
information began at the very producer
very top you have the producer then
underneath you have the village that
you're in sort of polluting marche in
some ways can relate to Knights valley
played emotion a village within burgundy
underneath it a vineyard named
Laperriere also kind of localized as you
and brings you into a more specific area
and then above all that you have Premier
Cru sort of designation of quality and
then vintage 2013 like like I said most
wines have a vintage so here you go from
you know being in France and burgundy
right down to a very small single
vineyard within a small village in
Burgundy
getting more and more specific as you go
moving into what some would say is the
most confusing wine label which is
German Riesling here lots of important
information but starting the very basics
again the producer in this case we use
the abbreviation JJ prohm vintage 2007
and then you get into the village and
the vineyard in this case anytime in a
German label and you see a word ending
in ER it's the their way of signifying
where it's from in the village so Byrne
castle is the village and then you see
er so burn Kessler means from burn
castle and then vineyard Badstuber
essentially the single vineyard in burn
castle and then in German Riesling
especially if you're not understand sure
what you're getting the level of
sweetness is indicated here so spade
lace is the level of sweetness it can
often have the word choking at the front
of it it says token it automatically
means it's dry and the word spade lace
relates to the ripeness level or in this
case off dry Riesling if you're unsure
the easiest way to check
to see if it's dry or not dries look at
the alcohol level something that all
wine labels in America have is alcohol
level not important just to know how
drunken can get you but also to know
what's in the bottle so at this point
eight point five percent alcohol
basically anything under 12 is gonna
indicate some sort of sweetness in the
wine and the lower the alcohol the
higher the sweetness so eight point five
percent uh alcohol would generally late
equate to a somewhat sweet wine to drink
lastly what I think is actually the most
complex because it has the most amount
of information on it but also the
hardest to read is champagne so
champagne is sort of the one of the most
exciting markets one of the places where
you can get most interesting things to
drink for maybe the best price but again
you're you're doing the same place so
you're in champagne you know that from
the cork in the bottle
in fact it's gonna have bubbles when you
open it but same thing you find the
producer charts on taiier in this case
it is a village wine or wine from a
specific village this case smurfy and
then there is a vineyard just like the
other wines previous lebar then you get
into very specific champagne things
champagne can have a variety of dryness
levels going from extra Brut or Brut
zero Bruton a tour all signifying very
very very dry high acid champagnes all
the way to sec in this case and it's
what's tricky about champagne second
champagne is not dry even though the
word second means dry in French so in
this case for this wine extra Brut very
dry champagne there's also in an
interesting part of champagne which
would be found on the back label
producers are starting to indicate the
varietal three main varietals in the
Champagne region in this case you have
Mooney a 100% which relates to what we
call Pinot Meunier and then if you're
interested in whether or not this is
produced by a large producer or the
cruise or mo inch and owner of the world
or a small grower producer this on the
back label you'll see where it says RM
for Michael domani Fedora which
essentially means the same guy
who grew the grapes also made the wine
or sometimes women they they grow the
grapes and make the wines if it's a
producer like Krug it would say nm which
is negocio my newphew law is essentially
meaning they'd buy the grapes and then
make the line